there he is he is putting his fist in
the air saying thank you as he emerges
down the step for the first time waving
to the media and getting set to step
straight in to the vehicle uh the former
president of the United States of
America
emerging down the steps onto the red
carpet and behind that vehicle obscuring
our view he is meeting his
representative in Scotland a woman who
has been at Trump's side
in his Scottish operations for a great
number of years and also standing there
is Eric Trump the son of the former
president they are engaging now in
conversation
uh in good spirits it looks while they
prepare to enter the vehicle and to head
north to
the golfing Resort that he boasts is one
of the best in the world a far cry from
the warmer climate of Mar-A-Lago where
this plane departed early this morning
and the president is coming around he's
waving at the Press
Mr President how do you feel to be back
in Scotland
Mr President
Mr President Mr President
and there we have it he said it was
great to be home he said
it is the home of his mother and
he put his fist in the air in true Trump
style and entered the vehicle very
quickly uh not
seeing anything too much which is
unfortunate but he did
remind us that this is
a place that he holds dear in his heart